what song were you thinking of doing
maybe in honor of
of howard stern in your hair maybe i'll
sing hair oh hair good
my mom used to cut my hair while i was
asleep and that would destroy you right
you didn't want your haircut
i was really into uh the grateful dead
for
a little while and i thought that i was
so fabulous because i
had to wear a uniform right so i would
grow my hair
really long and i wouldn't cut the ends
and it would get uh
really really nappy on the ends and like
kind of dready and i got so excited i
thought it was
i just thought i was the cutest thing
that ever uh even though
you know some girls were kind of grossed
out about it so what kind of song we did
came out of that when you um well i
thought about
identity and i thought about what
my hair meant to me when i was younger
since i went to a catholic
school with uniforms your hair was the
only thing you had
it was really the only thing i had we're
bonded by
the things that challenge us and every
night at the show
the fans when we would do meet and
greets and when i would meet them i'd
always stop the tour bus on the way out
because there's always thousands of them
waiting and i would try to sign as many
autographs as i could
and they would always tell me these
stories and they would write me and they
still they write me these
really long letters and i read them all
right and the letters are about
you know my mom doesn't like this or my
dad doesn't understand why
you know i talk the way that i do you
know just like all these stories
and hair became not just about
what i'd been through but what everyone
had been through yeah this song and the
album sort of became about the journey
of not just me but of
my generation and my fans and
how they feel and how much they
entrusted me with these stories whereas
you almost imagine i remember the the
pop singers or the rock stars that i
would
meet you know i never would have said
i'm so depressed or
you know i need you i never would have
said any of those things because i would
have been too afraid
that they would have so you like that
they uh open up to you and you get
inspiration from yeah well i
it means something to me it means
something to me that they trust
me go ahead please
[Music]
whenever i'm dressed cool my parents put
up a fight
and if i'm a hot shot mom will cut my
hair at night
and in the morning i'm short of my
identity
[Music]
i screamed mom and dad why can't i
be who i wanna be
[Music]
i just want to be myself and i want you
to love
me for who i am
i just want to be myself and i want you
to know
i am my hair
[Music]
i've had enough this is my prayer
that i'll die living just to squeeze my
[Music]
i'm not a freak i'm just
[Music]
my
[Music]
i am
sometimes i want some raccoon or red
highlights
today i like my cruella highlight
just because i want my friends to think
i'm dynamite
and on friday rock city high school
i've got dance bangs to hide that i
don't stand a chance
a chance i just won't
be myself and i want you to love me for
who i
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm not a freak
[Music]
i swear i'm as
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
i just wanna be free i just wanna be
me and i want lots of friends that
invite
me to their parties i don't wanna change
oh
i don't want to be ashamed i'm the
spirit of my hair
it's all the glory that i wear my hair
my hair
it's all the
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
this is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i am my hair
this is lady gaga on sirius radio with
howard stern
[Music]
i am my hair
[Music]
beautiful